see did you see did anybody see
[Music]
my name is Mallory and I am NOT a fan of
cats my name is Alison and I hate cats I
haven't really had many great
experiences with them they're just kind
of little jerks they're not affectionate
they just wander around and cause
allergies they have attitude issues and
I don't dig it chromes and whiskers is a
cat cafe where we have about 20 rescue
cats in the space what we do is we grab
them from Ella's high kill shelters
bring them here so they can live here
until they get adopted I don't know what
to expect I might freak out a little bit
after these three days I'd be really
surprised if I ended up with one after
this hi welcome to Crimson whiskers
thanks to excited I'm a little nervous
oh we're gonna start you with some
litter boxes oh really starting at the
top I feel like I'm panning for gold but
but the opposite so always be careful
when you're mopping to not get any of
the cat toys this is chemical and we
don't want that to come in contact with
this okay now it's time for me to feed
these cats there you go oh sorry kitty
there you go
hi everybody welcome to cousin whiskers
and we have a chai thank you for
anything I should know in particular
sassy cats are purple collared oh well
those are gonna be my favorite this is
it huh just pet him they don't really do
much else we're not handing out toys
we're playing with them yeah okay
hello so I had this one moment with this
cat misty at first our moment is like
just totally separate she is one of
anything to do with me and then somebody
told me if you blink when you look at
her she'll be into it blinking it misty
pretty fast and she's looking at me and
she blinks back I feel like we
communicated
do you guys come to cat cafes a lot we
come here three times a week she's a
patient Wow seriously like Brooke that
to me was a really emotional moment that
changed my perspective of it about how
cats can affect someone they - at the
cat cafe a lot of these cats were
getting a lot more frisky than they were
yesterday
a lot of sassy so it's my second day
here at the cat cafe and it's Adoption
Day my little one he's purring she likes
you mama I'm having a little bit of a
weird experience I have made sort of a
connection with one of the cats and I
won't like usually feel a bond to cats
but I don't know this this little girl
has something special about her she
feels a bond towards you because she
does not let people hold her the day was
different
I caught the attention of a certain cat
here and she caught my attention I
wouldn't say it's gonna change my
perception on liking cats in general but
definitely boggled my mind a little bit
that I could feel connection to a cat
I'm a little bit emotional about misty
leaving she was my only buddy she came
from a hoarding house so she was living
with like 30 other cats and now she's
like a completely different cat okay
misty you are officially in your forever
home
[Music]
it is the last day I feel like I've had
some pretty good moments with cats but
uh-oh
hello so do you want to start
introducing some cats to some people
sure I'd say if I was gonna have to get
a cat it would be this one cuz sue she's
the best right here she's the one that
I've wanted wet since I've been here
she is pretty awesome who's this this
one is Bernie you have cats uh no I
actually am not really a cat person
they're not super affectionate thank you
haven't met and snuggly Kat yeah Kat
teach us actually how love in a way the
dogs don't you have to pay attention to
how they want to be loved like this one
doesn't really like you to touch down in
this area the tail starts with being a
little bit yeah but I get in here I'm
suddenly everything's fun I will say
they have grown me a little bit over the
past couple of days this is birdie she
was brought in by her owner who had kept
her in a bathroom for a year so she had
a bunch of like dreadlocks and stuff on
her and so they had to brush them all
out so now she really loves being brush
she wants to get four of the kitchen I
will get you the bag and kitty treats
she is actually pre-approved to adopt
karina chant to chat with her she is I
don't knows what I like my pasta curry
yeah she's awesome Karina I didn't
expect to have a bond with the cat and
seeing somebody else like so interested
who's already approved to take her home
it's kind of crazy but I would be happy
either way with her getting a good home
so she's an awesome cat and she deserves
a good home so
[Music]
you
[Music]
so it's the end of my three days here at
the cat cafe I think I definitely
changed my opinion of cats
I don't want Karina TV in the beginning
I did not like cats and I was so
overwhelmed with how I felt about Karina
today I wouldn't say I'm a cat lady but
I will say that next time I encounter a
cat I'm gonna start petting it and I
think we're gonna have a good moment the
fact that I was crying over this cat was
pretty significant in my book I'm gonna
fill out an application and try to adopt
cream cuz I can't believe that
[Music]